mein kollege sven thomsen bei der
innenstadt von bonn und konnte
tatsächlich mit den p giga demonstranten
sprechen in dresden wäre das nicht
möglich gewesen denn dort redet man
nicht mit der presse
was verstehen sie unter islamisierung
und was stört sie daran unter
islamisierung verstehe ich eine immer
breiter werdende bewegung und tendenz in
unsere europäische kultur in unserer
tradition in unserer gelebten werte
einzugreifen
wobei ich das den menschen die er musste
den islam angehören nicht übel nehmen
sondern im islam steckt bereits drin der
trend zur erweiterung
ich kann jedem grad ich habe überhaupt
nichts wirklich wundert mich dass man
sich aufregt über die salafisten die
ihre koran verteilen die leute so eine
koran lesen sie sollen ihn ausführlich
lesen besonders die sure 4 besuch für
acht die für 2010 eine wunderbare
lektüre um den islam zu verstehen der in
sicht die tendenz trägt sich
auszubreiten und wir eröffnen dem islam
zum tür ja hier in bonn bad godesberg 90
wurde behauptete ganze in einer talkshow
dass es höchstens 100 frauen gibt die
vollverschleiert rumlaufen in ganz
deutschland gehen sie mal zwei stunden
nach bad godesberg sender oder hier
ansässig ist ja das widerlegt ja hier in
muffendorf sagt jetzt aufgrund der
flüchtlingsproblematik gar kein
weihnachtsbaum aufgestellt werden
viele gerichte gehen im familienrecht in
soziales bereits nach der scharia vor
also ich meine oder fahrscheine
buschkowsky in berlin was dort abläuft
wer das nicht sieht
ich verstehe wer auf dem land wohnt ja
und da kriegt wenig davon mit aber in
den städten ist die islamisierung
bereits so weit fortgeschritten dass
menschen bereits wegziehen und warum ist
es für sie jetzt gerade jetzt so
problematisch denn muslime leben ja
schon sehr lange bei uns jetzt kommt die
ganze diskussion hoch ist es aus ihrer
sicht die zahl derer die hier bei uns
leben größer geworden liegt es daran
oder was ist aus ihrer sicht das problem
wird sicherlich größer aber auch die
anspruchshaltung wird größer und unsere
bereitschaft nachzugeben wird größer
dass das problem wir leben unsere werte
nicht mehr durchgängig wir geben nach
vertrauen darauf dass die andere seite
genauso empfindet genauso demokratisch
denkt und handelt wie die ja das tun sie
aber nicht
ein muss ein gläubiger muslim kann nicht
demokratisch sein
er kann sich anpassen für eine gewisse
zeit lang aber im islam steckt drin dass
in dem moment wurde in der minderheit
bist darfst du dich anpassen eine
zeitlang du darfst sogar lügen tag ihr
aber wenn dann die mehrheitsgesellschaft
hast lesen koran durch wahrscheinlich
haben sie da getan dann tun sie es mal
darf ich sie fragen wie sie sich fühlen
wenn sie als nazi betitelt werden das
konto von ich fühle mich davon nicht
angesprochen weil ich nämlich kein nazi
bin und auch nicht eigentlich recht
stehst und noch ich bin dafür dass hier
in deutschland diejenigen die arbeiten
auch ihre gerechte rente bekommen und
dass man nicht hier das sozialamt der
ganzen welt ist
dafür bin ich nicht woran machen sie das
ganz konkret fest an welchen argumenten
dass wir wie sie sagen das sozialamt der
welt sitzen welt ja das mache ich daran
fest
wir haben 300 außen sinti und roma die
als hartz4 empfänger auf hartz iv
angewiesen sind und von diesem staat
leben und es kostet milliarden und die
können nie index wird werden und das
kann nicht sein dass die arbeitende
bevölkerung hier schuftet immer weniger
rente bekommt und immer mehr sozusagen
ihr ihre seife abzuholen ohne überhaupt
mal gearbeitet haben sie stellen einen
zusammenhang her zwischen einer niedrig
werden
rente und mehr ausländern sinti und roma
hier könnte man nicht auch ein ganz
anderen zusammenhang herstellen zum
beispiel dass die löhne seit zehn jahren
in deutschland real immer sinken was ja
nicht direkt etwas mit flüchtlingen oder
ausländern zu tun hat nein das hat mit
ausländern und flüchtlingen überhaupt
nichts zu tun denn diese zuzugehen das
soziale system aus dem ausland das ist
ja erst seit etwa 23 jahren aktuell
vorher hat er das gar nicht
stattgefunden wir kennen viele muslime
die mögen das land und wir mögen die
muslime
wir mögen keine islamisierung
das ist der unterschied muslime und
islamisierung ist zwei paar verschiedene
schuhe
das wissen sie selber sie fragen nach
dem grund weshalb jetzt das aus bricht
die demonstration gegen die
islamisierung 1970 gab es drei moscheen
mittlerweile gibt es über 3000 musik die
präsidentin unsere großartigen
präsidenten sagen der islam gehört zu
deutschland vor 40 jahren hat kein
mensch darüber gesprochen
das sind zb hinweise dass er eine
islamisierung stattfindet und wenn sie
die stadt die stadtbilder die straßen
bilder sehen wann weiß eigentlich jeder
bescheid und weshalb gibt spd haben sie
gestern bei auch gesehen wie dann die
frau schwan der sparen unter springer
die diebe giga.de wieder so wie gesagt
das sind ja alles leute die sind einfach
verwirrt weil das leben so kompliziert
geworden ist kommt nicht so recht mit
dem ding das heißt also diesen alle blöd
die leute sind alle blöd es gibt keine
probleme in deutschland es gibt keine
islamisierung in deutschland die leute
verstehen nur nicht wir müssen sie
aufklären so fühlen wir uns nicht ernst
genommen